hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen is
contaminated everywhere but we've cut
the source of the entire problem I'm
pretty sure there's only a little bit of
oh no there's just fertilizer in there
so the slime is almost gone and it emits
contaminated water admittedly I did not
know that but hopefully that's not gonna
do too much to my supply of fresh water
unless it's exactly like to contaminate
an oxygen kind of contaminates the whole
thing I hope it doesn't because then
I've got a whole nother problem but
after we research sanitation services
we'll actually be able to purify this
entire area and in doing so hopefully
rid ourselves of everything that has
been plaguing us thus far which namely
is contaminated oxygen but from that
point we will be able to continue on our
way and that is apparently the drip drop
of contaminated water which I didn't
know it was gonna do that for the
outflow pipe I wish I would have known
that but I didn't so I'm just gonna
prioritize building of this dump
hopefully that'll out collect over there
I don't need to do it much more in fact
I'm pretty sure it's gotta be almost
done oh yeah okay is it done
is it done why is it keep going
insufficient resources how is it using
more slime huh okay it's done it's done
it's dead there is no more the bio
stiller is done and I can destroy it now
so I'm just gonna do that I don't even
need it anymore do I I don't need it why
would I need it I don't it's just a done
holy [ __ ] it's done the slime is gone
forever and it looks like we just
researched sanitation services which is
awesome I'm going to do power regulation
next but tomorrow that means we got air
deodorizer
perfect so I can use this right here
because that way this is pretty much the
source of it
I'm gonna build three I don't know how
much it's gonna take and I don't know if
it's gonna be powering anything like
that but I've got three of them
hopefully we're gonna be able to pump
this [ __ ] out of here get me some
obsidian up in here I need to build me a
deodorizer I need to prioritize that
don't I I need to stop abusing my
priorities okay but after this once it's
done I'm gonna let it run for a bit
we're gonna see how the oxygen does
which I think it'll be okay
I think it's gonna do well this is a
matter of carrying on what happened
oh we just researched okay powered
regulation done okay interior decorating
I'm gonna do that next good good good
nice oh hell yeah whoo I can make a
shower that'd be nice
sure people would like that actually I
can make it right here no I need an
inflow in an outflow
now I mean I need to make pipes for a
shower I would need like a whole
plumbing system and I don't have that
[Music]
whoa hey buddies how you doing in there
you enjoying yourselves
I shouldn't have killed you okay so we
did the research so the problem is we
need a filtration medium and I don't
know what that is what is a filtration
media is it like is that just a raw
material or are we talking about
something else here wait
oh whoa okay all right then oh it's
working it's working it's working okay
so what these needed what are they using
and sand are they using sand they're
using sand Yes No maybe so I think
they're using sand yeah they must be oh
okay so I dug out a lot of sand from
when I just was over here but that's
okay
that's actually good that's really good
okay so those are working now yay maybe
I shouldn't have had all three right
there maybe I should just have one there
I don't know if they need power by
themselves but I can always build more
all over the place and that is just as
good so air deodorizer there's a lot of
contaminated air right there there's
some contaminated air right there oh
we're gonna clean this bad boy we're
gonna clean this bad boy out
oh we're gonna clean this bad boy out
okay so we're doing really really good
what are we researching right now
nothing so fine dining in the [ __ ] we
don't need to do anything about that
oh boy alright um combustion medbay
insulation oh man a coal generator
hydrogen generator into your decoration
we got all that stuff pressure
management let's do fine dining why not
maybe we could because food seems to be
the next thing that we don't have a lot
of how much you're gonna turn this
priority back John five
so those are being scrubbed we probably
need a lot more sand but that's gonna
come from digging over here which I
think we're gonna do very soon so I can
get rid of this piping I'm pretty sure
but I'll leave it there just for now
because I don't know if we're gonna use
it right away not gonna use it
whoa okay another person then that came
quicker well Brennan your double bowel
level-2 mozzarella anemic oh boy you
know what what Saturday Allah I like me
some cheese so you're doing fine buddy
boo
you're gonna be fine so what I need to
do is I need to sweep up everything to
get more sand for this stuff that's full
already geez all right well that's nice
but at least that's got materials where
they need to be is that still running
that's not running yet but that will be
running they'll be running soon enough
we just need to sweep up everything but
I don't know where we're gonna sweep it
up we don't have a lot of storage so I
guess I could put more storage here so
yeah I don't know it's the best thing
that I can hope for so what we have in
this episode what we have is we have a
lot of stuff and we've got a lot of
solutions to our problems in terms of
like the air purification and whatnot
and you know we got more people to help
out the problems we probably need to get
food a little bit higher up there which
I'm probably gonna we're all gonna base
that out in here I have this and then a
bigger battery here and then another
food processor here there and then you
know what I'm gonna cancel these I wish
I didn't put that there
then microplush sure so that's fine
we're a little stressed I get it
especially Lenny Lenny is just a big old
ball of stress but everyone else seems
to be dealing just fine because at least
they understand that the world may not
be nice but we're gonna try our best so
I know I know I know I know that things
are not very happy in this place but at
least we will be okay I'm not gonna be
great but we're gonna be okay okay so
I'm gonna let them finish this up for
now I'm gonna let them do their thing
they're gonna keep going that's gonna be
absolutely fine whatever it's all good
in my neighborhood but next we need to
make a move
we need to make a good move to make this
someplace actually livable and the only
way that we're gonna be able to do that
is by building a new now I'm a little
bit worried about all the chlorine gas
over here but I want to provide a good
home for my family so what we've been
doing is we have been like we've been
we've been researching a lot of stuff
and we'd get in been getting them
nuances of what this stuff is but that
doesn't mean that we're a hundred
percent where we should be there's a lot
more that we could do here and I'm
hoping I'm hoping that once we like
excavate all of this stuff we'll finally
be able to go where we need to go we'll
finally be able to do what we need to do
we'll finally be able to provide these
people with a good home to live in I
don't know when that's gonna be but it's
gonna happen so I'm just gonna let them
run for a bit while I plan because I I
have a lot of plans that I need to do
and I don't exactly know where I'm gonna
go what I'm gonna do those things but
I've got it and I've got it all under
control
okay so I've let them do their thing for
a little bit but what I've got here is
I've got the beginnings of rooms then
I'm gonna be building and I don't know
if I'm gonna have them like this I might
actually have these doors not be there
yeah I don't think I'm gonna do the
doors no cancel that just happen to be
big rooms and this one's a bigger room
I'm just not gonna go near the chlorine
just yet until I know how to deal with
that but they have rooms and they have
airlocks and the airlocks will keep
things in hopefully so when they're in
hopefully that means that the air in
there will stay you know normal we can
put an algae thing in there
for oxygen production there should be no
other reason for them to be in there if
they're just in there for you know just
being there for what it is so this must
be built on the ground so we can have
basically wanted the front and one the
back and that should be more than enough
to deal with all the carbon dioxide
that's gonna be in there right I hope
anyway
and maybe maybe not oh boy another guy
man these are coming faster and faster
all right Ernestine dimensionally an
epic ant build well that's not good
narcoleptic divers lungs hey I like that
une Ori the body builder I can hello
nori come on in we got a lot of work to
nori yeah oh my god they're running out
of oxygen here holy [ __ ] they need a lot
of oxygen ok so yeah I get it
oxygen seems to be oh my god oxygen is
dwindling fast ok hold on I did not see
how bad the oxygen situation was so we
need to solve that right now we don't
have algae what do we not have algae oh
god damn it guys I told you to why
haven't you [ __ ] done this yet get the
goddamn algae got it I don't know how to
get I don't know how to get algae other
than just grabbing it out of that thing
and we need more oxygen production in
now gotta be priority number one
priority power connections to them
that's got a pre priority well this is
bad they might die Oh No yeah that's not
good also these algae terrariums don't
seem to be doing exactly they don't
doing enough we need a lot of algae that
person just pissed their pants where did
all this contaminated water come from
someone just [ __ ] themselves over here
Gus was at you did you guys get the
algae please tell me you did thank you
you did ok but we need a lot more algae
than that so the thing is there is slime
here that can be converted into algae
but I just don't oh yeah well I think
mozzarella just [ __ ] himself that's good
to know
you know I'll just give this alright
well we are doing poorly this is going
badly the goodliness of all this stuff
that is going is not as good as I
thought it was going to be in fact it's
much more badder than I thought it might
have been but man so the problem is
these will stop if gas pressure reaches
maximum so that means they just have to
eventually clear out on their own how
long that's gonna take
but jeez
my rooms aren't gonna be built soon
enough and there's just not enough algae
how do you make more algae is there a
way to make more algae is it to do with
the planter box like could it just be as
easy as making planter boxes because I
hope so if it's not then I might be
royally screwed yeah cuz if we can't
make more algae so many of these like
devices just run purely on algae I know
they don't build algae how's that a
thing how do you build how do you get
more algae is there just no way to get
more algae is it literally cuz the
resources around me are saying that
algae is about to reach its limit I'm
not gonna be able to reach enough and
like I know there's a way to make oxygen
out of water but that doesn't stop the
fact that carbon dioxide is gonna build
up anyway I mean I know there's I know
there's um I know there's definitely the
scrubber oh no oh no everybody is
stressed as much as you can be that's
not good oh this might be the end of us
oh this might be the end oh no no the
colony is troubled by stress I don't
know how to fix it
oh boy yeah yeah yeah we say got me
overlays that's nice
hi odor hi decor lo decor man the
problem is the way I've built this whole
place is illogical the way I built this
is not in any way listening to the way
you know you should build something I
should have carved it out like
individually I should have should have
been much more studious about where I
was gonna go I should have done a lot of
things that I didn't do
oh man and I feel like I've betrayed my
people because I didn't know I didn't
know I didn't know guys you've been
subjected to such horrors and now you're
gonna run out of algae and then you run
to run out of oxygen and then everything
is gonna die
I don't know trying my best but I feel
like my best just isn't good enough
lashing out oh no they broke out in a
fight oh I can't help you
Lenny has always been stressed whoa
Lenny did you just break something Lenny
did you just break that Lenny you
[ __ ] Lenny is your feelings oh no oh
it's all going to [ __ ] isn't it it's all
gone to [ __ ] I should have tried harder
I should have known better I should have
done everything better than what I've
done now I can't live with my shame and
Max has to clean up the mess it's grown
into such a kerfuffle that I just don't
see the proper way to be able to to to
fix all of this I wonder what awaits me
in the darkness it doesn't seem like
there's enough doesn't seem like I could
do enough it doesn't seem like I could
do anything for these guys
where does it end where does it begin
how do I do this like how can i reclaim
everything that I've done up until this
point how can i reclaim it
I might have to scrap and start over but
I can't and unhinge the systems that
I've put in place the only systems that
keep these people alive but it's
dependent on resources that I just don't
have anymore
oh no oh boy I should have thought more
about this I should have been building
rooms as I was digging out instead of
letting him live in the dirt yeah Red
Alert
I don't know a red alert means red alert
is happening I just want you all to feel
even more stress than you already were
which is maximum which is totally my
fault I understand this is totally my
fault I am 100% at fault here I just
wanted to say how sorry I am for
misleading you okay so anyway I'm gonna
end this one here I I really don't know
I don't know how to fix this because
I've built such a monster here a such an
illogical monster by the way but I've
built such a monster that I don't think
I can bring it back from here but I
think that I've learned enough to be
able to start over and start fresh and
build something that's actually worth
building and something that won't kill
everyone in it which is gonna happen
eventually I just don't want to watch it
happen
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching I have learned a ton
about this so the next time I come back
to this I will be able to do this much
more efficiently whose last name Gus I'm
sorry good Gus Gus come on red alert
Gus has gone crazy dude somebody stop
Gus all right well Gus is happy now all
right so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]